you ready
want to get married
screaming
why off to Alaska okay I'll call you
when I land
hello Mrs Lerner your husband was on a
helicopter that went down in the Pacific
Jesse
at first it was so hard to let go
I refused to admit
but then I started to think that the
good days could be good weeks or good
months I'm finally ready to live again
Emma Sam are always remember
I guess you all know that I've been
madly in love with Emma for a few years
now the family family
hello sweetheart it's Jesse I'm alive
I can't wear that to reunite with your
long-lost husband
[Music]
I'm engaged
y
[Music]
beautiful life together and then we all
thought he was dead and you found love
again with a great guy no matter what
you do you're gonna break somebody's
heart
that was incredibly verbose but accurate
I just wanted to love me more than she
loves him
that was wildly inappropriate I'm gonna
stop no man for God's sakes just keep
talking
most not a person that loves her the
most I can't lose him Maria so don't go
tell him
[Music]
are we really not going to talk about
your husband-in-law I what